- So, a couple of your older
projects have gotten new life.
I don't know if you know this,
but we hear that there's a
potential "Freaky Friday" sequel
and "Summer School" is blowing up online.
Like, did you expect that 35 years later?
That is, it's all blowing up.
Like, people are wanting the sequel
and now they're talking about this again.
- Well, the first one is because
Jamie's talking about it.
- Yeah.
- And you know Jamie.
- [Kelly] Yeah. I love Jamie.
- Right? I do too.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- And I've known her since she was 15, so.
- [Kelly] Oh, wow.
- If she's talking about
it, then it'll happen.
- [Kelly] It's probably gonna happen.
- 'Cause all things happen.
- Yes.
- That's right.
- But it's, did you ever
expect the other one though?
Summer, what? Like for 35 years later?
- "Summer School"?
- Yeah. "Summer School."
Sorry.
- Yeah, no, no. Yeah, no.
- I was just so thrilled that Carl Reiner
was interested in me to play this part.
And then my wife read the
script at the same time.
Said, "don't go near this. Don't do this."
But we have very different
opinions of material and-
- Yeah.
- Things like that,
which is healthy, but I just said,
"He thinks I can do this."
- Yeah.
- So, I'm gonna do it.
- So, I went and did it.
- I love that.
- And all those kids, you know?
(audience applauding)
- But I love that it's
like blowing back up.
I just think it's cool
when it comes back around.
It's like music, people like Mike,
I hear young kids-
- Yeah, great soundtrack.
- Talking about music
and I'm like, that's like from the '70s.
Like, what?
- Yeah.
And all those people were young
and just starting out at that time, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So, those kids were all over 30
when they were playing
high school kids, so.
- Of course.
- Every one of 'em had an
idea after every scene.
"Hey, Carl, hey Carl,
hey Carl. Can I do this?"
And he'd go, "Ha ha ha ha. No."
- No. (chuckles)
(audience laughs)
Stick to it.
- Yeah, and but so many
of the little threads
at the end of every scene
that he let the camera
roll on are in that film.
- Oh, cool.
- And I had a chance to
work with him later years
laying down a track for
the movie years later.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And a chance to sit with him
for four hours and do that.
And I loved that opportunity
to finally tell him what he meant to me.
- Oh, that's so cool.
- [Mark] Yep.
- Yeah, you like to tell people that.
I like that about you so
far in this interview.
You like to like, let people know
that they like made a change
and an impact in your life.
That's cool.
- I was telling you that on the way out.
- Well, nobody, not
everybody does that. Yeah.
- Why?
- I don't know.
(audience laughs)
I don't know. Maybe they
feel foolish or whatever?
But like yeah.
- You do that all the time.
- I do, I'm like, well, I'm a
very chatty person in general,
so I tell everybody everything.
- There's a kindness in that.
- Yeah.
- It's not just being a chatty person.
It makes me feel good to tell someone
that they've made a
big impact on me, yeah.